this interview is getting weirder and
weirder
hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
today's video is sponsored by buildbar
and we'll be looking at another harpist
bazaar wedding today from comedian
tiffany haddish
but first let me tell you about my
sponsor buildbar oh my gosh it's snack
time lovers and you know that means i am
getting into my stash here so these
build bars are super tasty and i really
don't like protein bars because i don't
like chalk masquerading as health food
but i like these bars because they taste
exactly like a chocolate bar
and they have a lot of protein in them
so today's flavor what are we getting
into
minty fresh hello hello
so let's do the mint brownie 17 grams of
protein
i don't know if i've had this one maybe
a half it's gonna feel christmassy
hello santa
this would be next level if i melted it
in the microwave for like 10 seconds
then put a little whipped cream on top
so good
doing that
doing that today now i usually have this
before bed but if i was going to do this
as like a post workout snack i want to
probably pair it with a source of carbs
from some fruit or maybe some oatmeal so
if you want to try these out yourself
check out the link in my description and
use my promo code
abbysharp15 to get 15 off of your order
now before we get into it feel free to
pause the screen or look at the
description to check out my disclaimer
including a trigger warning to those
with current or previous experiences
with disordered eating so of course i'm
going to be talking about macros and
calories and analyzing this diet so feel
free to skip this video if it's not
supportive to your journey and do not
forget to subscribe to the channel and
ring that little bell so that you never
miss out on an episode all right
i'm hungry have my appetizer let's eat
usually i stretch i look at my hands
and i say oh i made it to another day
new chance for new beginnings and then i
pass gas then i'm like what am i going
to eat fun fact
apparently women's farts smell worse
than men's
i would not have wanted to be the odor
evaluator on that study board and i'm
also not so sure that i'd want to
disclose the nature of my research at
dinner parties if i was the head
academic on that study like imagine
spending years of your life devoted to
the chemical composition
uh people's farts but anyways whatever
brings people joy moving on
there got some chicken from last night i
go ahead i put that in a little pan i
warm that up in the oven so then i go
out to the garden and i got strawberries
back there i got some kale back there
got some chard celeries and i eat the
strawberries right the dirt right out
the dirt and i break off some of the
kale break off some of the chard break
off some of the celery and then i put
that through my little juicer
okay so it wouldn't be a celebrity
interview without celery juice and i
want to make it clear that i have
nothing against
celery juice or juicing any vegetable if
you enjoy the taste
the reason i troll on celery juice is
because of the typical double dose of
pseudoscience commentary that
accompanies celebrities and influencers
drinking it
it's like people cannot just drink the
damn juice without giving you a bs
tutorial on its alleged nutritional
benefits
as for the rest of the meal
i do appreciate that tiffany doesn't
seem to care so much about just having
conventional breakfast lunch and dinner
foods like her meal is legit the most
random thing of life but we've actually
got a fair bit of balance on board
so we got protein in the chicken
and we've got some fiber and
antioxidants in the strawberries and
vegetables
now i do think we could bump this up a
bit to make it a little bit more of a
satisfying meal by maybe throwing the
chicken on some bread for some carbs and
adding like a little cheese or savory
spread like tahini pesto avocado or
olive tamponade or some fat but yeah i'm
still just relieved that we didn't get
an earful about like medical medium with
this clip
let's see what's next
mostly i drink tea i love especially in
the morning if i got like extra time or
if i'm out of town a lot of times i'm in
hotel rooms so i'll drink turmeric and
ginger tea first thing in the morning
great you guys know my rules on morning
drink rituals
coffee tea black cream sugar whatever as
long as it's not accompanied by
pseudoscience wellness culture bs
i'm here for it and a tumeric ginger tea
sounds like a nutritious and delicious
option
not caffeinated enough for my liking but
to each their own so then you have to
call like room service or you got to be
like hey guys make sure i got some
scrambled eggs and avocado and tomatoes
and a hamburger patty okay so this is
apparently tiffany's order when she's
not like 20 feet away from her garden
and again the girl is clearly more of a
savory hearty breakfast person and
that's cool you know we got protein in
the eggs and hamburger fat and fiber in
the avocado and a little bit of fiber
and tomato
but since there's probably a fair bit of
animal protein in this meal
i would either go have seas on the
burger and then have some toast on the
side for some energizing carbs or just
do eggs and then save the hamburger for
lunch but again what i'm appreciating
here
is that even though this reads like a
purposefully low carb keto style meal
we're not getting a woo explanation for
tiffany's diet choices shoved down her
throat after every breath
it just seems like
this is what she likes and i respect
that resp spt what are you doing to
maintain that fantastic body to tell
them the truth not a damn thing um look
i like to work out in groups i prefer to
do like stairs i like to do the baby
shark ab challenge
how did i not know about this baby shark
challenge
i'm totally gonna work this in with my
kids like
parenthood and fitness
finally become one
i love it but again i also love
tiffany's attitude here
so what she's describing is what i would
call joyful movement
so she said she likes working in groups
and walking and doing some hokey youtube
workout that apparently was
choreographed for eight-year-old girls
but she's not doing it to change her
body or maintain her body as she says
she's just doing it because it probably
feels good or it's fun
and she enjoys it and that's great
that is sustainable movement typical
lunch for me would be like a salad or if
i'm in a place that's cold i want a
pastrami sandwich like i want some
pastrami i want like lentil bean soup or
chicken soup today i was craving some
fish
some red snapper fried from mel's fish
egg that is all like my favorite kind of
food too i personally
love all that and salads are always
great of course we just want to remember
to make sure that they're equipped with
the hunger crushing combo and not just
straight up lettuce with a few limp
slices of cucumber and tomatoes in the
mix
so we want to make sure we're bulking
that up with some protein like chicken
tofu beans edamame
we want some fat in there like nuts
avocado seeds and dressing
and some fiber rich carbs with some
sweet potato quinoa buckwheat or some
bread
i also love me a good pastrami sandwich
especially on a cold day with a side of
soup just keep in mind that most deli
meat is pretty high in sodium so i
personally feel better pairing like a
sandwich like that with nice fresh salad
and then saving the soup which is also
pretty salty for another day
and then if she was feeling like the
soup then i would personally pair that
with like a few pieces of toast smeared
in some avocado or something like that
for some healthy fat
ditto with the fried red snapper now
obviously i have no qualms about
occasionally enjoying fried food
especially because in this case we're
getting a solid source of protein in
that option
i would just try to bring in a little
fiber into the mix with maybe like a
colorful salad or some coleslaw on the
side so that way it's not beige on beige
on beige you know what i'm saying like
color is a beautiful thing for snacks
throughout the day i'm eating red vines
sometimes a sip of five hour energy
drink almonds apples oranges
nectarines
ooh dried apricots right you get the
baggage right because and then you pour
almonds in there now you shake that up
now you got your own special trail mix
okay so this is a eclectic selection
here
first of all for my candy lovers i'm
never gonna tell you that you cannot
have your licorice fix
there were so many great snack options
in tiffany's hit list here so if she was
feeling like the red vines i would say
let's dress up those naked carbs by
pairing them with a source of protein
fiber and or fat
so like a handful of those almonds would
be a solid snack in my books
ditto preparing any of those fruits with
some nuts seeds cheese or yogurt also
it's interesting to me that she's vibing
on the apricot almond combo because they
actually come from the same prunus
family
so a lot of people don't know this but
apricot pits
taste remarkably like almonds and
they're actually often used to flavor
italian amaretti and other almond
flavored desserts
so yeah i would say her foodie intuition
is
spot-on it is a perfect pairing and
together it's rich in fiber protein and
fat
hats off to you chef
that and fruit by the foot
that's in case i meet a man
yeah you gotta have your edible tape
measure close by to know what you're
getting into
obviously
uh but also where am i 90s kids at
how many of you used to wrap those fruit
by the foots like around your thumb and
then suck your thumb until it turned
wrinkly and bright red
yes
those were the days
i do hope that my kids get to experience
the pleasure
that is a disgusting sticky red thumb
but speaking of red let's talk red food
dye found in products like fruit by the
foot
now first of all i want to premise this
by saying we don't need to fear these
foods or call them out as toxic or
poison
there's actually no evidence that food
coloring like the infamous red dye 40
found in this product is problematic for
the masses
and based on current evidence the
environmental protection agency fda and
the who has listed red dye 40 as a low
concern at normal intake levels but of
course some people may experience
allergic reactions ranging from
migraines to mild rashes and hives
i actually myself have a mild allergy to
red dye 40 so this is one of the only
foods that i actually try to limit
there's also some evidence linking red
dye 40 to behavioral issues in a very
small subsect of children so research
suggests that about eight percent of
kids with adhd
may have behavioral symptoms in relation
to synthetic food colors
likely related to inflammation chemical
changes in the brain and mineral
depletion
now while restricting synthetic food
dyes may be an effective treatment
option for reducing behavioral symptoms
in kids with adhd
it's likely a very individual thing so
again this is not meant to serve as a
source of fear or concern for the masses
honestly i'm always hesitant to even
talk about these kinds of things because
the way i see it is that
if these foods don't bother you
then there's no point stressing yourself
out about them
but if they do bother you or your kids
know that thankfully a lot of brands are
moving towards more subdued food based
food dyes so i do expect that packaged
snacks like this may soon follow suit
usually dinner is like i like steaks i
like lobsters i'm saying all the
expensive stuff right now in case any
minces out there that want to take me
out to dinner this woman is a genius
gotta give it to her also i mean these
are solid protein options
i do believe that in general we want to
try to limit our consumption of red meat
for environmental reasons and also
considering that most steaks are higher
in saturated fat beef does have the
largest greenhouse gas emission per
kilogram so for environmental reasons
alone i do recommend trying to limit
consumption
now lobster in contrast is generally
wild caught so while it may not be so
sustainable for our bank accounts
american lobster is considered a
certified choice by monterey bay's
seafood watch oh i love to have like
chicken and dumplings for dinner chicken
is a main thing i sometimes i try to eat
lamb um i just i can't it bothers me i
think about mary and i say dang she had
a little lamb also tastes a little bit
like musty armpit that is
a perfect way to describe lamb
a musty armpit i agree
i also do not like musty armpit flavored
meat
not trying to get people's yum but it's
also not for me
but i do
love chicken and dumplings and i think
like most casseroles
i think while it's often painted as
being like unhealthy comfort food
i actually see it as an inherent
opportunity for balance so we've got
protein in the chicken carbs in the
biscuits fat in the ruined creamy sauce
and we've got free range to add in as
many vegetables as we want
so carrots and peas are typically
traditional but i also like parsnips
green beans celery corn butternut squash
and bell pepper too my alcoholic
beverage of choice is vodka occasionally
i would dip off into a little wine or a
sangria which is basically wine with
fruit because i love fruit and then you
know wine is nothing but fruit juice
that's been sitting for a while i mean
the woman is not wrong
and by that theory wine should totally
contribute to our five to ten servings
of fruits and vegetables a day
but i mean
alas
that theory is just proof that there is
definitely such thing as too much of a
good thing
also sangria is my drink of motherhood
and i'll tell you why
i can't drink at night anymore because
it messes up my sleep and it gives me a
headache in the morning
and when you are woken up for the day by
your kids at 5 a.m on a sunday
you do not have time for a hangover so i
am all about the day drink and i just
feel like sangria is a totally
appropriate accompaniment to brunch
am i right you're goddamn right people
ask me do you ever get angry
yes but it's the parasites inside of me
when they are hungry and they don't eat
they take over my mind and i'm pretty
mean to everybody okay i think she's
thankfully joking about the parasites
but sadly
most people on tick tock are not
apparently everyone and their grandma
has a parasite and needs some kind of
detox in order to [ __ ] it out
but here's why that is obviously bs
first of all while parasites are more
common in third world countries they do
affect millions of people in the u.s
alone and while usually benign they can
cause serious illness so i'm not
discounting that this is a real problem
a lot of the popular over-the-counter
parasite supplements right now though
contain herbs like wormwood which does
have some evidence for its use as a
natural antiparasitic adjunct treatment
but
it might not be as miraculous as often
stated
interestingly one of the big studies in
2018 that claimed that wormwood was more
effective at clearing a parasite than
standard medication
was since retracted for potential
inaccuracies of the data so
yeah that is obviously not good now a
lot of these cleanses also appear to be
maybe doing something because they
contain herbs known to have laxative
effects
so it's like suddenly
boom
things feel or look different than usual
and i know that most people doing these
cleanses on tick tock report seeing
something unusual in their stool
but
are they gastroenterologists trained to
identify different worms or parasitic
organisms
no
no they generally
are not
and even if we were to assume that these
supplements could in fact help detox the
body from parasites
you would have to for sure have an
actual parasite
to detox from and only a lab test can
provide accurate results
not just looking at the contents of your
last dump after you eat a papaya or
something and if said test did reveal
that you had an actual legitimate
parasite
you would probably want to consider the
protocol that your doctor prescribed
not what some online tick tock
influencer suggests so if you are in
fact suffering from symptoms like weight
loss increased appetite abdominal pain
diarrhea vomiting sleep disturbances
fever weakness and anemia
please
speak to your primary health care
provider asap to get to the root of what
might be causing the issue moving on
so my other favorite most favorite snack
is pickles the big ones that they sell
in the big jars and then you put a noun
later or a jolly rancher or
a peppermint in the middle
whoa delicious flavors to savor let it
get the pickle and then dip it in
kool-aid powder now they sound like
diabetes it feels like success i mean
i can't say i'm not intrigued like the
dill pickle with kool-aid or the jolly
rancher
i can kind of see like we got the super
salty tangy sweet combo going on
but the peppermint
i don't want to yuck her yum but
not for me
like that seems like it'd be like
brushing your teeth and then drinking oj
i don't know guys leave me a comment
below if this is something that i need
to try or if tiffany is just trolling us
here
like i'm getting
watermelon mustard vibes going on
but as for tiffany's statement about it
feeling like diabetes
i know it was just said in jest she is a
comedian but i just want to point out
that contrary to common belief
sugar does not
cause diabetes
there may be a strong correlation
especially with sugar sweetened
beverages but it doesn't flat out cause
it
here's what we actually know from the
research on diabetes and sugar sweetened
beverages
so evidence suggests that drinking just
one sugary drink per day does appear to
increase the risk of type 2 diabetes by
about 13
independent of any weight gain that it
may cause this may be related to excess
high fructose corn syrup which seems to
promote inflammation and localized
insulin resistance
now the sugary drinks may also
contribute to weight gain and body fat
which are additional separate risk
factors for diabetes
but what's really important to note is
that this is just one
teeny tiny piece of the puzzle here
and diabetes risk is actually quite
multifaceted and complex
so exercise smoking sleep apnea and
genetics
also play a significant role in fact
there's a 40 chance of type 2 diabetes
with one parent having it and 70 chance
if both parents have it so yes drinking
kool-aid on the regular may add a layer
of risk but it's not automatically going
to cause diabetes especially in the
context of an otherwise healthy diet
when the ice cream truck comes and you
get the bag of doritos and you buy a bag
of fritos and you mix those two chips
together you tell them to put two scoops
of chili inside that bag and then the
cheese on top with the jalapenos and
then you get the little plastic spork
okay this this is good i've had that
many times at like food truck rallies
and in california at random pit stops
and i agree the spork
is key here i'm not even going to
attempt to make this more balanced
because you're probably not going to
find
a vegetable at a lot of these places to
bump up the nutrient value
but just know that a salty higher fat
meal like this
isn't gonna make or break your health
bank
if you love your frito pie from a gas
station
just enjoy it
if you want to make it at home and maybe
make it a little bit more balanced for
every day
i would suggest picking up some lower
sodium chips making a big batch of
veggie bean packed chili
throwing on lots of avocado diced
tomatoes bell pepper and lettuce
and just like
spork it up cucumbers and tomatoes
cut up together and then you add a
little bit of apple cider vinegar some
laurie seasoning salt some garlic
seasoning salt and some black pepper
okay so i feel like if she wanted to add
this little sprightly salad to the meal
with her frito pie
we'd actually have a solid meal right
like we'd have carbs in the chips we'd
have some fiber and protein in the chili
fat and the cheese and some more fiber
and antioxidants in the veg
delish and i also really love me a tangy
vinegary cucumber salad
you know what else i love ain't nothing
like some good corned beef and cabbage
now i can give you the full recipe but
we don't got time for that so that's
another really great meal option i have
irish roots so i do love me some corned
beef and cabbage though of course do
keep in mind that corned beef is a
processed meat so it's something that
we'd want to enjoy in moderation because
it is higher in salt and fat and
nitrates but i love pairing with cabbage
for like a cheap and cheerful
antioxidant rich side throw in some
potatoes and
we got a classic
irish meal with some fiber protein and
fat
she's good but i make this killer kale
salad i don't know if you ever had kale
salad before but this kale salad that i
make
i can open up my own restaurant this
woman is all over the place with her
food pics and i am
so here for it
uh i love that her preferences are
varied and that she likes the
stereotypical la health foods like kale
salad and green juice and ginger tea
but also is down to like crush a frito
pie and loves her jewish deli meat and
her southern dumplings like
i feel like we could get along
so
on that note what can we say about
tiffany's diet well i kind of feel like
this is what eating should be like
it's not governed by random food rules
it just kind of is what feels good in
the moment to your body
and when you're actually in tune
you're probably gonna legit feel like
having cucumbers and apple cider vinegar
after eating chili and cheese on top of
doritos like i don't know if comedians
are by nature just a little more chill
and laid back compared to other
performing artists that i review
but i do
really appreciate the flexibility here
i didn't hear any moralizing language
about food and even when her food
choices were stereotypically like super
food based
i didn't get a long spiel about how they
cure cancer or detox the body or cleanse
the body of a parasite so it seems to me
like this is just what tastes good or
feels good to her
and that is like so refreshing to hear
sure not all of tiffany's choices are
the most nutrient dense or balanced like
sometimes they're higher in saturated
fat or salt or other times i think we
could bump up the satisfaction factor by
adding in some nutrient-rich carbs or
veggies
but healthy eating to me
is all about intention
a kale salad is obviously very healthy
if it's what feels good to your body or
it can be unhealthy if you're shoving it
down because gwyneth paltrow said you
should
likewise a burger can be healthy if it's
what your body is craving in the context
of a balanced diet or it can be
unhealthy if it's part of some elaborate
cheat day meal
intention is
really important in these scenarios
honestly
i really like this woman
more reviews like this one please and on
that note that is all that i have for
you guys today thank you again billbar
for sponsoring this video if you liked
it please be sure to give it the thumbs
up
leave me a comment below on who you'd
like to see me review next subscribe to
the channel and i'll see you next time
on abby's kitchen bye
you